[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
grand jury proceedings in the police
shooting of a kentucky woman
rihanna didn't pose a threat to anybody
she was literally in her underwear
did police think brianna taylor was at
the trigger he said
she was the one that shot us and an
actor files a police report
after getting punched plus harvey
weinstein faces even more legal trouble
our analysis is right here on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody so glad you're
with us here on law and prime daily i'm
erin keller along with brian buckmeyer
and terry austin we're breaking down
15 hours worth of recordings releasing
the grand jury proceeding surrounding
the death of briana taylor
taylor was killed after police executed
a no-knock warrant
on her apartment in march though one
witness and the police claim they
did announce their presence one officer
was charged but not because of taylor's
death
people took to the streets of course to
protest after the announcement of the
grand jury's decision to indict the
officer
for wanton endangerment for firing into
taylor's neighbor's apartment
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
has since said prosecutors did not ask
the grand jury to consider
additional charges nor did cameron's
office ask the grand jury to consider
charges against
the other officers involved that's
because he says his office determined
the other officer's actions were
justified three officers fired their
weapons that night
sergeant john mattingly was struck and
has since recovered an fbi report
concluded detective miles cosgrove fired
the fatal bullet that killed brianna
taylor
detective brett hankinson was fired from
the police force for wantingly and
blindly firing into taylor's house
through a sliding door hankinson told
investigators in march that
he first assumed brianna taylor's
boyfriend kenneth walker
was the one who shot and killed taylor
here's some of his internal department
interview which the grand jury heard
i asked him who else was left in the
apartment he said his girlfriend
and i believe he said she was dead
inside the apartment and he's asking him
what was going on or whatever and i'll
refer that conversation to body kings i
think that's all
and i don't i don't remember exactly
what i said it was that conversation or
you heard
uh the american assistants who's dead
and he said uh
my girlfriend is dead inside the
apartment and immediately my mind was
like
did we kevin did we come to something
that already happened that's what
flickered in my mind was that he and his
girlfriend have it
he killed a girlfriend products that's
what i kind of in my mind at the time
thought
and he said no she was shooting at me
with her knot
over nine millimeter i don't remember
his exact words but
on the first body cam but he said that
she was the one that shot at us
and that she was dead in the apartment
brian buckmaier and bernardo velona
review the entire 15 hours of recordings
bernarda good to see you here again on
law and crime daily so what key points
jumped out to you
as a prosecutor related to this grand
jury presentation
so aaron having been a prosecutor for 16
years i'll tell you that the role of the
prosecutor is to seek justice
and not merely conviction it seems that
attorney general daniel cameron forgot
that role forgot that duty now as the
prosecutor presenting the case
the prosecutor serves as the legal
advocate
and the jury is the fact finder
throughout this entire presentation of
15
hours i can tell from the very beginning
that these prosecutors made the
determination
beforehand of what the facts were and
therefore
did not present the charges of homicide
for the grand jury
to decide by the prosecutors doing that
they unilaterally
took the job away from the grand jury
to make that decision make that
fact-finding decision
and that's where the prosecution went
wrong here for there to be any faith
in the criminal justice system there has
to be transparency
and here there was none i think it was a
huge miscarriage of justice
for the prosecutors not to present the
homicide charges for the grand jury
to decide if you don't present the
charges then the grand jury can't decide
them yeah bernardo so you think this
entire process was backwards brian you
listened to all these recordings what
are your initial thoughts
yeah so as a defense attorney one we get
a non-indictment a
we call it a blowout because you have to
present so much information as a
defendant
that you get rid of all of the charges
that didn't happen here the bar is so
low and what the attorney general did
here is they insulated themselves
they didn't have the actual witnesses
testify in fact
they had officers who interviewed them
to show the recordings and then when the
grand jury who had
phenomenal questions asked them
follow-up questions they couldn't
because the people who have the
information weren't really there
yeah remember the grand jury is
listening to recordings of the officers
involved not
the actual testimony of the officers
involved here okay
let's move along grand jury also heard
of course a recording from one of the
officers who was inside taylor's
apartment
law and crime's terry austin has that
side of this very complex story terry
erin detective miles cosgrove did not
testify in front of the grand jury but
he did speak with
investigators twice cosgrove was
interviewed by the department in march
12 days actually after the shooting he
was interviewed again
in september by the kentucky attorney
general's office
cosgrove said he was told in a briefing
that taylor was considered quote a
soft target and insisted he heard the
other officers
announced themselves as police while
they knocked on her door
he described entering taylor's home
behind sergeant john mattingly
and encountering gunfire
i am immediately overwhelmed with
bright stretches and darkness and what i
describe as
a movie realist doing that chicken where
you see white black and white
he told
so i know john my friend that i've known
for 15 years
has been shot in
in this confined space and i know this
person is down
and i and i sense that there's still
this
these gunshots happening so during this
flashing light
i'm seeing this this human genome
terry so it's certainly a harrowing
scene that we're hearing described but
is there enough detail here is there
enough of a chance for the grand jury to
get in there and get questions answered
in your opinion
i don't think so aaron we need more
details here and more importantly the
grand jury needed more details for
example if the warrant
was originally a no-knock warrant who
decided to knock
they were entering a suspect's home why
didn't they have a body camera running
it you know they saw that taylor had no
weapon
why did they shoot in her direction
there are just so many
unanswered questions here so many
questions and we're sitting here asking
them terry i'll see in a couple of
minutes because still ahead here on long
crime daily we dig further into the
briana taylor grand jury recordings
and later on a possible avenue for an
appeal for the man accused of
brutally stabbing his parents and trying
to get rid of their bodies using
chemicals
even cooking methods lawn crime daily
returns right after this
back now to the brianna taylor case
where we are analyzing hours of grand
jury recordings the kentucky attorney
general's office presenting two and a
half
days worth of evidence the grand jury
returned only an indictment against one
officer for watching endangerment
for people in a nearby apartment so
we're taking a closer look at what was
and was not presented to that grand jury
law on crime daily's brian buckmeyer
explains brian
the prosecution's recommendation and
arguments were not released to the
public
but we're now learning members of the
grand jury were allowed to ask questions
during the proceedings on the final day
of the proceedings an investigator with
the state attorney general's office
answered some of those the first
question
is were drugs money or paraphernalia
recovered from apartment four
and the answer to that is no they did
not go forward with executing the
initial search warrant that they had for
brianna taylor's apartment
and the third question is why body cams
weren't activated
i can't answer that you know i don't
i don't know why body cams weren't used
for that
i believe they've changed their policy
since this incident
was there a formal plan between the
seven officers
as they made approach to the to serving
the warrant
i'm not aware of one
and ben crump the high profile civil
rights attorney representing briana
taylor's family is asking kentucky's
governor to appoint a new special
prosecutor to reopen this case
here's part of my recent conversation
with krump about whether or not
the police announced their presence
before entering taylor's apartment
we know that there are a number of
different stories about whether the
police announced or whether they didn't
based on the changing testimony that you
have reviewed
what do you think really happened when
those officers went into that apartment
do you think they knocked do you think
they announced or do you think they did
neither
well based on the evidence we have
the witnesses said they did not hear
them knocking and announcing
kenny walker who was in the apartment
that he didn't hear them knocking
and announcing so based on the plethora
of evidence that is not self-serving it
seems to me that they were exercising a
no not
warrant and common sense will tell you a
no-not warrant
permits you not to have to not
everybody's here now to wrap this up
bernardo you're the former prosecutor i
got to get back to what the one officer
said if you've got a warrant to
investigate what's alleged to be this
big drug operation why do you not
execute it so i find something very
fishy about that aaron i do not believe
that they did not search that apartment
because
there is footage of detective hankins
then going
back into the apartment after the
shooting itself
especially since he should not have even
been in the apartment
since now is the crime scene also we
know that crime scene detectives did go
into the apartment
they took pictures they looked through
evidence so i find that hard to believe
that that wasn't done the answer is you
did not find anything
so terry i got a big picture legal
question here so hearsay
is allowed in grand jury proceedings
usually
you allow it to try to get charges
against someone in here it feels like
they
use hearsay to try to insulate people
from testifying
yeah it does seem that way i think they
went out of their way to protect the
police officers
you know they made sure that the fact
that they went in there
and they didn't discover anything you
know they kept that to themselves i
agree with bernard they went in there
and they
didn't discover anything so you know by
saying they didn't search it i think was
hiding something and you know admitting
hearsay evidence to protect the police
officers is definitely
not the right way to go and brian you
seem to be in complete agreement here
hankinson cosgrove and mattley should
not have testified their defendants
but every other officer that was there
every other person who lived
in and around the area should have been
able to come to the grand jury and give
their information because this grand
jury needed more
and i even though we don't have it i do
not believe they were properly
explained what the law was and what
self-defense was because it's not
applicable here i'm glad we have these
recordings because in essence they're
telling
us the four of us that there need to be
more questions answered brian
exactly and they were they were asking
all the right questions and that's why i
believe this grand jury
really wanted to come forward and speak
and when we come back right here on law
and crime daily the case of the young
man accused of stabbing his parents to
death and cooking his mother's head
on the stove plus the actor you know
from ghostbusters and honey i shrunk the
kids
it's roughed up in new york stay with us
for that and more
comments made by defense attorneys
outside the presence of the jury may
shed light on a possible appeal for the
man convicted of murdering his parents
it was guilty as charged for joel guy jr
after prosecutors presented evidence
that he stabbed his parents to death
over thanksgiving weekend
and then dismembered their bodies
including cooking his mother's head on
the stove
and trying to use chemicals to speed up
the disposal process
among the key pieces of evidence was
this jailhouse call from the defendant
to a friend
on that basis i think you should
probably just sort of
consider me dead i don't know what
to say i mean i don't know
if there is
outside the presence of the jury the
defense objected to the use of that
phone call here is some of the
discussion which could point to possible
grounds for an appeal
we want to preserve for the record our
argument that this call could be or
would be fruit of the poisonous tree of
both those things
had mr guy not been arrested on the
faulty warrant he wouldn't have been in
jail making the call
they wouldn't have gotten the faulty
warrant if but for the illegal search of
the knoxville house
so we just want to make sure that when
we come back on appeal if we do
no one will say that we waived the fruit
of the poisonous tree argument i
certainly don't think that you're waving
i disagree with it but i think you have
done a good job mr hall said in
preserving the record
okay terry so we know some of the
evidence gathered against the defendant
at his apartment in louisville was or
louisiana excuse me was
thrown out because authorities didn't
have a warrant that evidence included
pictures of the bodies
i get that under the fourth amendment
but this new argument they seem to be
saying that the defendant's arrest is
also fruit of the poisonous tree and you
should throw out anything you said
behind bars
well you know technically as you know
the fourth amendment does
protect us from unreasonable certain
seizures and
technically the ill-gotten evidence
could keep
out the arrest as well but you could
argue there are exceptions to that
rule there are a couple of exceptions
and one of them is that
if you could get the same evidence and
inevitably
discover that same evidence then you
know you can use it the other thing is
they could get a warrant that was
a good warrant and they could also use
the evidence so there are ways to get
around that and
use the evidence and i think they can
make those arguments obviously the
warrant argument is no good
but they could say that the evidence
would have inevitably been discovered
exactly terry you took the words right
out of my mouth i'm thinking inevitably
someone would have happened upon the
crime scene they would have tried
tracking down the sun they would have
found at least something here
brian does the argument work yeah i
think the inevitable discovery
doctrine applies directly here
especially when you're thinking about
some of the items that were found at
walmart
i mean parts of the bodies are
decomposing in a bin you've got the gas
on the side here eventually they would
have gone and looked at those items gone
back to see where they were purchased
and then got the video that really
damaged the defendant here in this case
i think it's a long shot make the
argument but i don't think it's gonna
work so the defense attorney here is
agreeing that the law was properly
applied i look and say hey the defense
made their record the judge was really
polite to the defense and said i think
you made your good point i just don't
agree with you that was cordial brian
yeah i mean this is one of those
situations where you got to shoot your
shot and if you don't
you don't know what's going to happen
down the road as the defense attorney
says you've got to make that argument to
preserve it down the road just in case
the appeals court takes a look well when
we come back here
on law and crime daily the off-screen
legal lives of three hollywood types
including harvey weinstein
against whom new charges are stacking up
on the west coast
less than a year after his sex crimes
conviction in new york
we will be right back
[Music]
the nypd is looking for a man accused of
attacking actor rick moranis officers
say the man seen
in surveillance video here was wearing
an i heart new york hoodie
and he struck mirandus in the head with
a closed fist and then knocked miranas
to the ground
the attack happened in daylight hours
just before seven o'clock
7 30 in the morning i should say moranis
is best known for his roles in
ghostbusters and honey i shrunk the kids
police say the actor was treated at the
hospital for pain to his head back and
hip
then later walked to the precinct to
report the crime
actor shia labeouf arrested in
california on misdemeanor charges of
battery and petty theft after
authorities there say he fought with
another man and stole the man's hat
the buff due in court in november to
answer those accusations
labeouf was arrested for public
drunkenness back in 2017
and on drunk driving charges in 2008.
former movie producer and convicted sex
offender harvey weinstein is facing six
new charges on the west coast
los angeles prosecutors are adding three
counts each of forcible rape and
forcible oral copulation
that's in addition to a list of charges
they've already filed against weinstein
the new accusations stem from encounters
with two women the sum total of all of
the charges weinstein faces in
california
involve five women and date between 2004
and 2013.
a new york jury convicted weinstein of
several sex crimes earlier this year
and he's currently serving a 23-year new
york sentence
after i was raped by weinstein in 2005 i
was confused
why didn't i scream why didn't i fight i
thought i was stronger and i hated
myself for being weak
that self-hate turned into shame and
guilt shame that i never should have
felt and guilt that was not mine to own
it didn't occur to me for quite some
time that i might actually start to heal
from
being sexually assaulted my single
intention was to help survivors hold
weinstein accountable
for his disgusting crimes i hope that
the sentence sends a clear message that
times have
changed and that more women need to
speak out for themselves and that men
and women need to speak out for each
other we need to show self love and
empathy to overcome
centuries of illogical thinking that has
normalized the sexual mistreatment of
women
this is hopefully just the beginning
terry we have an extradition hearing in
upstate new york on december 11th to
decide whether to move weinstein from
buffalo where he's behind bars to
california to face these charges so
this is going to get really interesting
from here on out it will and you know we
saw this coming because the d.a jackie
lacy in
los angeles she was the one who
announced these charges
while the trial was going on here in new
york and we know he's already facing 23
years here the question is
what will he be convicted of in
california and how many years
will he get out there and i've got to
tell you i think it will be a conviction
because he's already been convicted once
and i think
jackie lacy is really out to make sure
that he's convicted in california as
well
brian is it possible for this guy to
even get a fair trial on the west coast
after what went down here in new york
everybody was watching here in new york
they know how it went down
so aaron i gotta almost answer that in
two as two different people if you're
asking brian bockmeyer the attorney i
think no he's not going to
legally get a fair trial because of the
overexposure of this case
and what happened in new york if you're
asking brian blockmeyer the person i
think he's getting as fair for the trial
as what he did to those women allegedly
and i think he's going to get his
comeuppance and his justice
brian buckmeyer with a bit of a split
personality here so you know
you have to feel for people who say
they've been victimized and people who
have convinced a jury that they've been
victimized
like those that we just watched exactly
um it's tough to see and i think uh
i was there myself as an attorney
watching here at the long crime trial
network and
it was tough to watch but i think the
right decision came about you know
that's why we have trials to try to find
the facts and get it justice and thank
you brian and terry of course for being
along with the analysis that's all the
time we have here on law and crime daily
we appreciate you joining us for our
discussion about justice in america
i'm dan abrams and this is the law and
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
[Music]
today
[Music]
you